let's go make it happen Monica I want a  beautiful best handshake in school  tamiya education is I moved in about the  same way everything public has moved  frankly ana.k 2 6 3 and everything you  do is micro managed by a district a  state legislature a Department of  Education today schools have a deficit  of cultural literacy they have a deficit  of knowledge about the human world in  the natural world I think there's a  prevailing sense that students are  graduating just adrift in general or  unclear on what life is for once I'd  really started doing my research on  class blood I kind of realized that this  was the missing piece Barney charter  school initiative is an outreach of  Hillsdale College and it's an excellent  way to reintroduce sound learning and  thousands of children attending  excellent schools has exciting prospects  for this country  [Music]